Напередодні нового року український уряд повідомив:
Київ уклав угоду з китайським фармаконцерном Sinovac Biotech
на постачання 1 мільйона 900 тисяч доз вакцини від коронавірусу - CoronaVac.
Новину супроводжувала хвиля не стільки полегшення, скільки критики.
Що це за вакцина? Чи справедливо критикують рішення українського МОЗ
і які інші вакцини допомогли б Україні подолати пандемію коронавірусу?
Китайська вакцина CoronaVac належить до так званих інактивованих.
Вірус вирощують на клітинних культурах і хімічно інактивують.
Коли вакцину вводять в організм, імунітет реагує не лише на спайковий білок, а на весь вірус.
Вакцини такого типу відомі давно.
Препарат концерну Sinovac почали розробляти ще 2003 року після спалаху SARS -
важкого гострого респіраторного синдрому - в Південно-Східній Азії та Канаді.
2020 року вакцину переробили й удосконалили.
Китайська вакцина дієва одразу проти кількох штамів коронавірусу Sars-Cov-2, стверджує виробник.
Може зберігатися за температури 2-8 градусів тепла упродовж місяців.
У неї зручне фасування: одна доза - один шприц.
Для вироблення імунітету необхідні, як і в усіх інших вакцинах від "ковіду", дві дози.
Китайський фармаконцерн Sinovac Biotech загалом спеціалізується на випуску вакцин.
Глобально визнаними є його препарати проти гепатиту й грипу.
Вакцину CoronaVac ВООЗ включила до своєї програми COVAX.
Наразі триває третя фаза клінічних випробувань: у Туреччині, Бразилії та Індонезії.
Перші дві фази отримали схвальні відгуки авторитетного медичного видання The Lancet.
Варто зауважити, що жодна з наявних у світі вакцин проти коронавірусу не пройшла третю фазу випробувань,
а сертифікували препарати за прискореною процедурою.
Українська влада заявила, що вакцинація CoronaVac-ом розпочнеться тільки після офіційної реєстрації щеплення -
про це, зокрема написав у телеграм-каналі президент Зеленський.
Він підкреслив, що ця реєстрація має "не викликати жодного сумніву".
Україна законтрактувала вакцини CoronaVac за ціною близько 18ти доларів за шприц.
Угоду розкритикували у соцмережах: мовляв, та ж Індонезія закупила щеплення по 13 з половиною доларів за дозу.
Та, як пояснив глава ДП "Медичні закупівлі" Арсен Жумаділов,
ціна вакцини визначається низкою факторів.
Приміром, кількістю: Індонезія замовила Китаю аж 140 мільйонів доз, пакування проведе сама.
Та головне - зголосилася на масові випробування CoronaVac.
Річні потужності Sinovac - 300 мільйонів доз вакцини.
Продавати свої препарати Китай планує у найбідніші країни:
Пекін виділяє мільярдні кредити країнам Азії та Латинської Америки на закупівлю своїх щеплень
Європейська преса охрестила це "вакцинною дипломатією".
Україні, щоби щепити хоча би групу ризику - а це 20 мільйонів людей - необхідні 40 мільйонів доз вакцин.
Нині, з урахуванням ВООЗівської програми COVAX, замовили чверть необхідної кількості.
Серед найпривабливіших для України часто згадують так звану "оксфордську вакцину" -
розробку компанії AstraZeneca та Оксфордського університету.
Це векторний препарат, який отримав дозвіл на масове використання.
Для виробництва такої вакцини використовують інший вірус - зазвичай грипу або аденовірус.
На ньому конструюють білок-шип коронавірусу - вектор.
Така вакцина тренує імунітет реагувати і на Sars-Cov-2.
Як і китайський CoronaVac, оксфордська вакцина проходить третю стадію випробувань.
Серед її переваг - ціна: близько 4 доларів за дозу.
І це нині найдешевша коронавакцина в світі.
Та умови зберігання - +2+8 градусів.
Ефективність щеплення AstraZeneca - 70 відсотків.
Україна поки веде перемови про закупівлю цієї вакцини.
Раніше у МОЗ заявляли, що саме цей препарат Україна може отримати у рамках програми COVAX.
Розробка німецько-американської компанії BioNTech/Pfizer має високу ефективність - 95%.
Це одна з найбільш інноваційних вакцин проти коронавірусу.
Раніше м-РНК-вакцина розроблялась як препарат від раку.
Вакцина використовує фрагмент генетичного коду вірусу,
що навчає імунну систему розпізнавати спайковий білок на поверхні вірусу й реагувати на нього.
Препарат уже дозволили для масових щеплень у Євросоюзі, США, Канаді, Ізраїлі, Японії.
До недоліків вакцини BioNTech відносять низьку температуру зберігання і транспортування - мінус 70,
і нетривалий термін зберігання після розпаковування - 5 днів. Вартість дози у Німеччині - 12 євро.
Також на основі матричної РНК розроблено й препарат американської компанії Moderna.
Однак цю вакцину можна зберігати за вищої температури - мінус 20.
Поки що її поставки обмежаться Сполученими Штатами - країна замовила 20 мільйонів доз першочергово.
Вартість дози - 15 доларів для США, 25 доларів для ЄС.
Одну з найскандальніших вакцин - російський "Спутнік" - Москва планує продавати на експорт по 10 доларів за дозу.
Цей препарат векторного типу розкритикували за непрозорі, спішні й неповні випробування.
Попри це, вакцина ще у вересні отримала дозвіл у Росії.
Про готовність щепитися нею заявила Угорщина, Білорусь та Венесуела.